hallo leute hier ist eure mal wanne und
heute kein mal tutorial ich weiß es ist
mir auch schwer gefallen aber ich hatte
mal lust auf was anderes ich habe mit
der lieben freundinnen der lara ein
video gedreht und zwar über gaming girls
und zwar wundert es mich immer wie
gaming girls von männern gesehen werden
bzw wie manche mädels sich selbst als
gaming girl hinstellen und es nicht so
ganz der realität spricht also ich weiß
nicht was finde figur sich daraus
gemacht haben aber hier nun die
männliche vorstellung eines gern wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und so
für die realität aus
[Musik]
am schluss gesagt das war's hier diese
woche etwas gefallen
das ist die wunderschöne lage die kennt
man schon aus hüther videos sie hat ein
paar lieder mitgesungen und ihre stimme
sei vielleicht hatte ich keinen schlips
getreten gefühlt und ich hatte beim
nächsten mal wieder eine das heißt mal
macht ein video oder auch eben nicht und
erzählt dass jede meurer mama papa und
dem postboten pause das auch instagram
twitter ist auf twitter gibt es auf
facebook und ist beim nächsten mal und
abonnenten nicht vergessen video einem
daumen nach oben
bis dahin und oben kannst der daumen
nach oben